in Demon Souls there are two types of
magic there are sorceries which are cast
by Sorcerers with their knowledge of the
Soul arts and there are Miracles which
are cast by clerics through their faith
to God these two forms of magic didn't
always exist long ago an ancient being
called the old one was awoken by a man
who thirsted for power with its
Awakening came the Advent of Magic the
church saw all Soul Magics that came
from this event as evil and as the
result of demons and their Souls on the
other hand though Miracles they claimed
were granted to the church as a way for
the holy to fight the old one in the
name of God the church is wrong the old
one is the source of all magic both
Miracles and sorcery and all along the
symbol of God was nothing more than the
image of the old one it's the biggest
twist in Demon Souls to think that the
clerics were no different than the
sorcerers they hated so much that all
along their faith was founded on the
evil they sought to destroy one guy
called scur probably realized this when
he found the Talisman of beasts a
Talisman of the church which can cast
miracles and sorceries indicating that
they both have the same origin when we
reach the end of Demon Souls and put the
old one to Slumber we will essentially
be removing Magic from the world for
without Soul Magics and miracles to
raise kingdoms men will be forced to
rely on tools Advanced weaponry and more
modern forms of of medicine and science
you might see what I'm getting at here
because I think this brings us to
bloodborne a game with the code name
Project Beast just like the Talisman of
beasts set in a city where people are
turning into beasts magic doesn't seem
to exist there's a character with the
maiden in Black's Voice who is a
character from demon souls and I can't
show you this footage but the word umasa
which is a prayer from Demon Souls has
been uttered by a character in blood BL
born we could be looking at demon cells
2 from a story point of view and even if
that's not true that's exciting
regardless of all that though I didn't
call this video Demon Souls 2 just
because of the potential story even
though there might be a potential story
there no I called it that because every
time the developer draws comparisons to
the souls series he specifically
mentions Demon Souls not Dark Souls
which is more recent and more popular
this is a strange thing but I put it
down to more than anything else the fact
that bloodborne is a PlayStation
exclusive just like Demon Souls was I
quote Miyazaki here by saying the format
of the game is very close to Demon Souls
it's in the action RPG genre and it
features a behind the back camera but
bloodborne he says has three powerful
themes first one I'm going to talk about
is the feeling of fighting for one's
life now you could argue that the souls
games have this theme as well these are
games where the fear of death is
Justified because you actually stand to
lose something unlike in most modern
games but bloodborne seems to mean Fight
for Your Life much more literally
essentially you are actually fighting
for your health when you get hit in
bloodborne you have a 3C period where
you can recover that lost Health by
striking out at your opponent as a
result you need to take a more active
approach to combat rather than a passive
one a passive approach to combat is
something that's favored in the soul
Series in bloodborne get up close and
personal with your enemy dance circles
around them and get revenge as soon as
you get hit you take a risk by doing
this but the better you are the more
calculated that risk will be the game
mechanics I reckon are all built around
giving more power to the offensive
player you can also press L1 to change
weapon modes extending your axe for
longer reach or splitting your sword in
half to wield two daggers this
drastically changes the array of melee
combos you have available to you when
you have a gun in your left hand hand
you can shoot enemies when they mid
attack to stagger them and put them into
a reposable state where you go up to
them and rip something from deep within
their chest there is nothing defensive
about the mechanics of bloodborne and
you just won't be playing this the same
way as you play the soul series for
example something might jump out from
behind a corner or in a dark place and
attack you and surprise you but now you
have to rely on your reflexes to get you
out of this situation where in Dark
Souls you would have just gone around
that corner with the shield up this is a
much more sort of thrilling engaging
experience there was this one part in
the alpha in particular where I went
into this really old pitch black house
right and every step you took made this
creaking sound on the old wooden
floorboards and if you stopped moving to
listen just for a second you could hear
the barely audible sound of enemies
breathing somewhere close and I didn't
know I could pull my torch out with the
d-pad at this point so you carefully
tread through hearing those floorboards
Creek until you hear an enemy coming at
you and making a noise and or maybe you
illuminate him with your torch but the
point I'm getting at is you rely on your
senses and your reflexes to get you
through rather than just progressing
with your Shield held high and you know
when you have more to lose when you're
really engaged in this way and you can't
just hold your Shield up it's a really
immersive experience when they said
Fight for Your Life they didn't just
mean the health back mechanic they also
meant in general you feel more
vulnerable and that is definitely
something I felt in bloodborne the
second theme is exploring the unknown in
the soul series you know who knows
what's around the next Corner one second
you're in a poisonous Wasteland the next
a volcano the major difference I can see
in bloodborne and souls seems to be that
bloodborne is a more consistent world
it's all built around a very central
theme where as Souls you can go to
drastically different environments
Miyazaki says he wants to capture the
feeling of remote towns that you would
have seen in the Victorian era uh stuff
that's really old and gloomy and Gothic
with dark Alleyways and dim lamps
carriages graveyards and wet streets
glistening with the light of the Moon
there's an incredible attention to
detail thus far and that comes from
having that sort of centralized theme
this town yanam is a town long known for
its medical advancements ironically it's
held in the grip of a bloodborne disease
that's turning its inhabit into beasts
with elongated limbs Claws and fur
everyone seems to be in various states
of transformation but the interesting
thing is no one seems to know that
they've turned into beasts they don't
have that self-awareness we are the most
humanoid and self-aware thing here
apparently because as I engage enemies
they yell away foul Beast or it's all
your fault these enemies are clearly
delusional they're the ones turning into
beasts why are they saying that and and
it makes you feel a sort of pity for
them you have to wonder what sort of
distorted reality are they seeing
through their eyes where you're the
Beast and they aren't it's one of those
things where the story is really
intriguing just because of things you
see in the world and things you hear in
the world and that's something I'll
touch on later but in terms of the
setting the only concern I have with
bloodborne thus far is that the settings
we experience might be limited to those
gloomy streets and the Eerie graveyards
I do like a consistent experience it
allows for a much higher attention to
detail but I also do like a bit of
variety that said we do clearly travel
outside the city's limits as we've seen
forested areas and this is only an alpha
this is only one small part of the city
who knows different parts of the city
could look drastically different but so
I am confident that they'll do more than
we've seen so far but I do think it's
going to be more consistent and if
that's not for you well anyway I
mentioned before that this attention to
detail makes you much more intrigued in
the setting Miyazaki has this intention
of us exploring the unknown and I think
it also applies to the mysterious story
and setting this city is so gripped by
some plague that it's going to be really
hard for us to infiltrate into it and
get to the bottom of what's going on we
see really intriguing things that make
us want to know more about the world I
was walking through this Courtyard right
and then I look down and there's this
sort of wriggling tentacled shadow on
the ground and so I look behind me to
see what casting that shadow and on this
building there is this massive
spider-like creature the size of a
skyscraper clinging to a building and
looking at me with about 20 or so eyes
as I progressed through the level These
Eyes actually seem to follow me and you
start thinking what is that thing it has
a Squid's body for a head the multi-eyed
face of a fly six human hands and this
really furry abdomen will I get to find
out what that is what created it what
the hell is going on in this city that
something like this can come to be will
I have to kill it at some point this is
what I think Miyazaki wants to convey by
his theme of exploring the unknown the
monstrosities you see leave you with a
lot of questions and it's really
intriguing so far in a way that I feel
like the soul series is kind of
forgetting the third powerful theme
Miyazaki talks about in bloodborne is
new online elements but so far from what
we've seen there really isn't that much
different from Souls so he must be
hiding something up his sleeve we've got
a taste of some of the online in the
alpha you open your online menu and you
get four options you can ring the luring
Bell which will attempt to summon
another player into your world the small
resonant Bell will summon you into
another player's World Parting Shot
allows you to leave another person's
world or it can also Force someone out
of your world and the notebook also
allows you to leave messages for other
players just like like the soap stone
wood there are rumors though and this is
talking about the stuff that Miyazaki
hasn't officially mentioned that players
might actually turn into beasts if they
succumb to the sickness meaning you
might have to kill other people as
beasts or you might be summoned into
other players worlds to take out the
other players who have become beasts
take all this with a grain of salt but
if that's in the PVP that's going to be
pretty damn incredible we could
essentially become the beasts that we're
hunting all in all although multiplayer
seems pretty standard so far and similar
to souls apart from the Beast thing so
these are the three most potent themes
and while they actually promise to be
more prominent in bloodborne than they
are in the soul series these three
aren't the only similarities the two
game share let's do a quick fire around
talking about all the other stuff that
is different and the same healing is
done with blood vs the use of which has
a designated button in the Triangle
button and also healing is always shown
now in the the top left in the alpha
these blood vs dropped randomly from
enemies and they were pretty plentiful
but we are unclear on how common they
will be in the full game or if there's
any other way to get them we haven't
seen anything symbolizing a checkpoint
yet but we have seen the incredibly
complex levels that are very reminiscent
of demon souls and dark souls in the
sense that you can unlock shortcuts that
will take you to drastically different
areas of the game this is something you
wouldn't have seen in Dark Souls 2 which
was a much more linear experience these
interconnected areas make me think that
we could be looking at an entire city
that is open world without any real
checkpoint or at least there might be
smaller segments of the city up for
exploration similar to how Demon Souls
had little levels that you could do let
me know what you think of that the one
boss we've seen so far is the cleric
Beast which was a really incredibly
aggressive enemy that could be taken out
when you figured out how to deliver
critical attacks the the fight was
really good it was really hard and once
you figured out how to do those critical
attacks the fight Dynamic changes
completely the only problem I have with
it was that you couldn't exactly predict
its attacks very well and also the
camera got in the way a lot because you
know when you fight a enemy that's
really tall like the last giant camera's
just always going to be a problem and
the camera was a bit of a problem with
the cleric Beast because you couldn't
actually see where he was attacking you
or when he was winding up for an attack
but it was a really good EXP overall uh
these critical attacks were initiated by
shooting his head which makes use of a
lot of the extra Mobility you have as a
character and you have to really dash in
there real quick and do your attack on
his head and it's a very sort of risk
reward boss battle the boss battles are
actually initiated a different way this
time around you will find the boss
you'll engage them in the area and then
you'll look behind you and you'll see oh
crap there's a fog gate there I can't
escape now this is different from the
souls games in the souls games you'll
always go through a fog gate to initiate
a fight but in bloodborne it looks like
you will initiate the fight and then
realize you're within a fog gate this
changes after the first time you've
engaged that boss after the first time
you've engaged them you will see those
fog Gates there all the time in terms of
difficulty like I mentioned before with
the cleric Beast it's really hard the
game is really difficult but the thing
is from has never particularly said that
they want to make bloodborne a difficult
game in fact I think a few times they've
said the opposite but the thing is with
from software they always say this they
never really say oh we're going to make
the game really difficult that's what
it's known for that's not what they
usually say they usually say that they
want to put gameplay first and that the
game is inherently difficult as a result
because that's the way they design their
games this means that gameplay usually
comes before difficulty which is the way
it's supposed to be done if you've
played the souls games you're going to
be very familiar with the controls
because they're more or less the same
triangle is your dedicated healing
button now L1 switch which is the mode
of your right-handed weapon L2 allows
you to fire your gun or perhaps get a
unique attack when you're dual wielding
or two-handing a weapon instead of
holding a gun and R2 can actually be
used as a charge up attack which you use
on enemies when they're not facing you
to initiate a backstab this makes it
much more difficult to backstab enemies
compared to the souls games rolling is
still your circle button though you only
roll when you're unlocked and you can
roll in any direction and you Dash when
you're locked on the dash seems a bit
faster but you can only Dash Left Right
forward and back and most importantly in
terms of the differences from Souls
games ragd doll physics they're back so
I covered all these things pretty
quickly because I think most of you
would have heard it before but there are
going to be some of you watching this
video who want to know more about the
gameplay and want to know more in depth
there are two great videos you can watch
that aren't by me there's one that's
really short and really concise by Dave
control live so he's got you covered if
you want to watch a 15minute video on
everything we know about bloodborne but
if you want to get a feel for the game
and watch something much more long form
then peeve peeverson will keep you
entertained for a good hour and a half I
really recommend that video if you just
want to watch the entire Alpha being
played through by someone who's actually
really good at the game and I just
wanted to put something out there that
was a little bit shorter and a little
bit more about the parallels we can draw
to the soul series if you have any
questions at all on this game then how
about you leave a comment on this video
and I might just pull some questions
from this comment section to do another
Q&A video I don't know if many of you
remember my last Q&A video you guys left
me a little bit scarred from that one
but I am Keen to do another one so if
you have any questions leave them down
below and if I can't answer you maybe
someone else will be able to but other
than that guys thank you for watching
and I'll see you in the next one
bye-bye